but we we have got to prepare ourselves
now to be ready because if you're ready
now the problems go away
they think you're sheep i mean i asked
you on a
podcast with you the last time where's
the line
what line do you have as an individual
that you say i won't cross
well i i won't go there i mean if i said
to you last summer
yeah they're going to tell us that we
can't have thanksgiving with our family
that we have to wear a mask all the time
and the president's going to make that
mandate
and they're going to shut down the
economy you and i
and everybody else would have said never
never
you know it's interesting i often think
now now that i've been taking some of
these positions that aren't thought of
as popular
or okayed by mainstream or whatever that
the only thing to fear is fear itself
and i've been thinking about that a lot
lately that
the more that i say the things that i
believe to be true that happen to be
against the mainstream things
the more i get over that because if you
can get over the fear
then if it's true that we're on a list
and they're coming for us
then we're on a list then we're on a
list and by the way pretty much
everyone's on the list and that's why
there's that famous thing
you know they came for the jews first
it's like we're all we're all part of
this thing
but it's a very strange time that you
can show me some of these things
founding documents from the united
states documents about saving jews
during world war ii and it feels like
something that's kinda now
only if people don't find their courage
yeah i truly believe and this is why i
think you're so powerful
courage is contagious it is people not
everybody's
a leader not everybody's willing to step
out
into danger you know not everybody's
willing to lose all their friends or to
whatever but when they see someone
risk everything and they see them
on a list if you can get them early
enough
they'll step out but the longer you wait
the worse it gets that's bonhoeffer was
a pacifist was involved
in vogstenberg's coup
how he's a pacifist he
he said there's nothing else we can do
at this point because it's too late
the people's hearts had turned to stone
and you couldn't turn them
we have to find a way to make sure that
our hearts and the hearts of everybody
we know
stay soft and see people as people
not enemies you know when i was on tour
with jordan one of the things that he
would bring up often because he would
talk about the parallels to
nazism to some of the authoritarian
movements of the day
and he would say to everyone in the
crowd he'd say you know there's 3
000 of you sitting out here right now
and i guarantee you that every single
one of you
would think that you wouldn't be a nazi
if this was 1936 germany
and that proves probably that you would
be
and i always thought that that was
pretty powerful we all think we would do
the unpopular thing we all think we
would do the risky thing we all judge
everybody by our standards of today
i'm not sure i'd stand in the end
i mean a friend of mine marcus
trell i said to him
how do you stand torture and not break
and he said glenn everyone breaks
everyone breaks he said
but the ones who break the fastest and
the loudest
are the ones who will say i'm never i'll
stand
oh i'll stand because they haven't
thought about it it's why i wanted to
bring my kids to auschwitz i need you to
feel it so you can think about it
and really look at this as a possibility
and once you do that and you realize
by the grace of god i'll stand
um then you're then you're ready
but we we have got to prepare ourselves
now to be ready because if you're ready
now the problems go away
they think you're sheep i mean i asked
you on a
podcast with you the last time where's
the line
what line do you have as an individual
that you say i won't cross
well i i won't go there i mean if i said
to you last summer
yeah they're going to tell us that we
can't have thanksgiving with our family
that we have to wear a mask all the time
and the president's going to make that
mandate
and they're going to shut down the
economy you and i and everybody else
would have said
never never i would have said you know
maybe they're right about that bad guy
yeah right you would have you would have
it's insane to think look where we are
and now all of a sudden that's normal
it's the new normal yeah they get you
with that phrase the new normal because
there's there's an implicit oh
accept it it's implicitly
it's here so you better accept it so the
thing about war
is war is just about changing
leadership borders and financial systems
that's what war is really
about for the people up at the top and
it's usually so horrible
that a society even great ones
never go back to the way they were
because
you're so willing to accept peace
i just want to go back to normal that
you never reset
back to normal and you'll accept almost
anything
here we are look at what we're willing
to accept at this point
and i know i did when they started
talking about the new normal i was like
no no i don't no no no i don't want a
new normal
i want normal normal yeah regular normal
we'll be just fine
yeah how many people now would just be
happy if we just
if we have okay this is a new normal and
they're going to start
you know letting letting things back up
but it's never going to get the way it
was
lots lots would accept that is that why
you care so much about history
and these things because you feel like
it kind of grounds you to do the current
events that you got to do you got to
wake up every day you do how many hours
a day
of talk uh at least at least and that's
a lot
that's a lot of air time i know how much
i talk and it ain't five hours a day
but is that why you care so much about
history because otherwise
you're just sort of spinning in the in
the
morass of the day i i know clearly what
i'm fighting for
i know clearly what i'm fighting against
and my son
was eight maybe and he started taking
taekwondo
and he had to go in to get his first
belt and
i don't know why but he didn't expect
there to be a crowd there
and when he was really young crowd
scared him
because of the
the stuff that has happened to me that
he witnessed as a little kid
crowd scared him and he didn't want to
be
around crowds and he didn't want to be
noticed you know
and so we're going and he's like no no
there's a crowd no there's a crowd
and i'm like rave it's going to be fine
it's fine it's just the parents they're
just like us we're just watching your
friends no no
no and he really freaked out so i had to
take him home while his sister got us
got her belt and i'm driving home and
i'm like what
do i say to him and
i quite frankly i was a little pissed
but i didn't want to be pissed at him
because he wasn't
you know he wasn't misbehaving and
and we drove home and i held his hand
the whole time but we didn't really talk
because i'm thinking what do i say
pulled into the house
got into the house and i knew exactly
what i needed to do
and i said come into my library come on
sit down in the library
and at that time my whole walls were
covered with artifacts and
men determined to be free and raul
wallenberg in the picture of the woman
that he
saved and a picture of him all of all of
the heroes
rosa parks everybody winston churchill
and we sat there on the couch i said
just want you to look at the walls
and he did and i said why do you think i
have them up here
and he said because they're all heroes
and they weren't afraid and they do the
thing
and i said no because i know
each and every one of them was terrified
of doing what they knew they had to do
they were terrified but they did it
that's the lesson of history
they're just like you abraham lincoln
was not a big tall statue
he knew he was going to die he knew it
he did it anyway he didn't want to
nobody
nobody wants to do you think gandhi well
ghandi may have because he was doing the
hunger strike
but that was against his people his own
followers
he was like you want you want to be full
of anger
and rage i'm not with you and until
my followers stop acting that way
i'll starve myself to death i mean these
these people were amazing
but all of them all of them had a change
of heart
and didn't want to do it bonhoeffer when
he was here in america
he escaped germany and he
went back to he came here to america he
was in new york and he was so
guilt-ridden that he left his
people in this dark hour that he went
back i think was on one of the last
boats
that went back and you could get back
into germany
he went back and he said to all of his
pupils
okay let's say you're an atheist let's
say you're an atheist so you really
believe that
but you don't have any other choice than
to take somebody's life
they didn't realize at the time the
example he was trying to get them
to convince him that there's no way you
could do that or to accept
convince him that yes i can do that he
he's involved with von schnaufenberg
he's taken to a concentration camp
in the end he's in a cell with a guy who
took the jews
up into airplanes until their heads
popped
he took the he took people and covered
them in ice and freezing
in the cold water and all of that stuff
in every hospital in the world
that book from the nazis all of those
stats are in
every hospital in the world and that's
why he was sent to a concentration camp
because hitler he he released all this
information
and hitler said what the hell are you
doing he said you know how many lives
will be saved by this information he
said
we're saving german lives not
everybody's life
he a prostitute double agent
uh and dietrich bonhoeffer were in the
same cell
they were all executed four days before
hitler died
the guy at the gallows remembers
bonhoeffer
because he thanked him he walked up the
stairs
he got there and the executioner kind of
held you know helped him up
and then put the noose around his neck
and bonhoeffer looked at him and said
thank you for your kindness good gallons
that's the person i want to be but
that's not a person you just become
that's a person you work hard to become
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell